[موسيقى]
يلعبون الكره باوراقهم وافخاذهم فقط ولا
يسمحوا للاعبين من الرجال او النساء
باستعمال ارجلهم او ايديهم او رؤوسهم حتى
اثناء المباراه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عاده
وشعوب
موطن لعبه البلوتا او الاولما احدى
الرياضات النادره في عالم الكره
والمتوارثه منذ مئات السنين لكنها لا تزال
حاضره ولها جمهور عريض هناك في ملعب يبلغ
طوله 40 متر وعرضه خمسه امتار يتجمع
لاعبوا البيلوتا وكل فريق يضم خمسه لاعبين
يرتدون ملابس تقليديه هذه الكره صنعت من
المطاط الطبيعي لكن وزنها يختلف بحسب
اللاعبين كره الرجال
غرام اما بالنسبه للاطفال هو واحد ونصف
كيلوغرام وبسبب الوزن الزائد للقراءه تزيد
الكدمات وردود والاصابات
انت متروسستان
[موسيقى]
اليوم الوطني